[Music]
based on what you're saying you sound
like a really nice guy Jay hey [__]
you Billy the bouncer had stabbed them
in the leg with a knife and the guy's
bleeding so they gave him 20 bucks put
him in the cab send him up
okay the world you describing
particularly from the early days is so
different to the world that we have now
yeah it is different but I mean that's
is a progress I don't know a rape joke
has the same career penalty as an actual
rape that doesn't seem
[Laughter]
fair Jay thank you so much for coming on
the show well thanks for having me as
everyone can tell you're a fan of cars
we'll get to that yeah we'll get to that
but before that look I remember growing
up and your show was so well established
you were hugely popular but people of my
generation and younger wouldn't have
followed your journey from the beginning
so we always love to get people like you
to tell us your story how did you how
did you get into comedy and standup and
and all of that well I grew up in a
rural area was born in New York City in
New York rather when I was nine we moved
to Andover Massachusetts which is about
30 miles north of Boston kind of rural
area so the idea of going into Show
Business you you know my mother is from
Scotland and to the day she died she
never understood what I did you know I I
can remember I had my aunt netti a
Scottish name and I heard my mother the
phone obviously my aunt what's Jay doing
now
and she saidwell he has a little skit
that he puts on from town to town and
I'm go M I don't like I stand in Town
Square and I sort of do a dance with
there's no conception of I mean it's a
kind of place where people go Kathy's
boy wants to be a ComEd oh it just
didn't seem like a viable profession you
know you come to Los Angeles and you
meet nine-year-old kids who want to be
lighting directors because their dad is
or their uncle is so they're all in the
business but growing up in a small town
you you worked at the sneaker Factory or
you worked at the plant or you were a
teacher or something that nature the
idea of going to show business really
did not seem like a viable alternative
and how how did you end up going into I
mean that must be well I went to school
in Boston and Boston
had thousands of students with no money
willing be entertained by people with no
talent I mean the colleges they put a
candle in the cafeteria it would become
the tut toe Cafe and this was the late
60s early
70s and it was a pretty serious time it
was mostly focusing stop your war
machine man that and they would have a
flashlight under their chin you would be
dark stop your War Machine and they'd
run over there stop your War Machine and
just like this sort of alternative
expand so the idea of doing standup
didn't really even seem like what it was
not something people thought was a
viable alternative then George Carlin
started to come in and then Robert cuz
see prior to that most Comedians and I
imagine same thing in England uh were
men in their 40s or 50s grew up during
either the war or in America during the
Depression times are rough kids with the
long I know has so long to pan through
them T these hippies all that kind and
then suddenly had this younger
generation talking about things that I
understood you know I remember George
Carlin's Class Clown album that's sort
of what ignited me I remember hearing it
and I would recite it not on stage and
then to get into it I would my own
stories at the end I would I would do
his routine just to get the Rhythm my in
my bedroom or something so and then I
put my own story and so the first time I
got on stage I just I was standing
backstage doing George and I walked I
tried to time it so when I walked out oh
well here's what happened to me when I
was in school and and and and that sort
of worked it worked pretty good so
there's a whole gener Richard prior you
know but nobody's better than we called
Richie back then but um I used to try
and go on I remember back in the 70s I
think Richard Pryor was the first guy to
do a comedy standup movie it was Richard
Pryor live at the Sunset Strip and for
about two months he would come to The
Comedy Store to break in the material
and killer nobody funnier than Richard
that's unbelievable and I remember
saying to mity who owned the place can I
go on after Richard every night you know
and nobody wanted to do it because you
just died but I realized I did not have
an hour's worth of material I had about
12 minutes because after following
Richie and you go on but it was good
training because I just threw out
everything that wasn't funny you know
Comics are inherently pretty lazy well
you know that joke work back in the 80s
yeah it's not the 80s anymore you can't
you people how old are you what are you
talking about you know I I I remember
seeing a comedian not that long ago you
know as to think about Nick in the paper
the other day and I go first of all
Nixon was not in the paper the other day
I don't believe you as an audience
member and you're doing a I'm not a
crook you know all that nobody knows
what you're talking nobody knows who
Richard nion is I mean but that's what
happens in your comic you just s of you
just keep doing it thinking well it did
work once you know it's like guys that
have a bad pickup line they got laid
once with it in the 90s and they've been
saying the line ever since that
you it's interesting that you say that
you do the it's so interesting because
comedians are like that oh no mate that
joke worked three months ago you go yeah
it worked once right right doesn't mean
it's going to work again and you're
talking about Richard
prior for People of Our Generation he's
a legendary figure what was it what was
he like as a person what was it like
working with him and watching him
perform well he was a great comic uh
Moody some days it was Richard sometime
Mr prior and you real oh okay he's
serious now okay hey Mr
BR yeah and then 10 minutes later you're
fine you know just odd did a lot of
drugs a lot of drugs you know and you
know he grew up in a wh House in peor
Illinois I think it's an or somebody ran
the brothel so you know just witness to
a lot of things at extremely young age
either inappropriate or just outright
wrong so you cut him some
slack um but really funny I mean to the
point
where it was it was so natural and you
know he was the first guy to use terms
like mother the [__] you know
and I remember Cosby would yell at him
you know Cosby the moral
equivalent stop using the FW stop using
but for Richard you never felt like he
was was using it gratuitous yeah it it
it was a vernacular he was talking as a
character and it was always just really
funny to watch you know uh oh he had
just I remember some of the you know
about two black guys of the urinal you
know and the standard theal guy one guy
says his water's cold yeah and deep too
you know just just those kind of jok you
know just like and yeah I mean he was he
was he he was really good yeah it was
just it was really a joy to watch him
work because it wasn't set up punchline
yeah it wasn't a guy goes into a bar it
wasn't that he was always telling a
story and playing a character and and
that's what really made it work yeah
what were those days like in The Comedy
Store in the in the 70s and the 80s
wonderful wonderful because to me you
know it's so funny whenever was he there
was a a series about it I'm dying up
here and the drugs and the dep
depression to me it was a joyous time
because I never met another comedian
when I was I was fortunate when I
started in New England in Boston didn't
have comedy clubs I work strip clubs so
I never knew how bad I was because
people are always yelling or throwing
stuff at you you know so if I got a
laugh at all I thought that was great it
wasn't until I there was a club called
Lenny on the turnpike which is a great
name but it was a jazz club and I got to
open for Miles Davis and St GS and Moos
Allison and Aman Jamal and rasan Roland
Kirk and I would please don't commun Jay
Len I'd walk on
stage and they were they were there to
listen because they're jazz people yeah
I never had an audience that listened
before it was always suck it up stage I
remember the first time I got on stage
first Jay Len and a guy goes we hate him
he suck and I'm think did they see me
come in how can they hate me how you
know of course they see it wasn't based
on anything it was just a rough joint
that's what it was so working that jazz
club it really made me appreciate the
audiences and the economy of words
trying to get to a joke as quickly as
possible without a lot of you know the I
think the reason comedians like to talk
to other comedians is when you talk to
regular people go right so I goes to him
right so like she goes back to me what
do you mean goes you mean
she they just trip over the yeah they're
tripping over themselves you know
comedians get to the point so it makes
it a fun conversation and Jay you talk
about starting out working strip clubs
that people who haven't done standup
don't know I mean I've never played a
strip club in my life thankfully but
even you know I've been similar
situations that's a horrible experience
as a comedian no it's a great exp enjoy
well I enjoyed it
because there's nothing worse than
silence and if they're not paying
attention it's not your fault yeah you
know you're up there okay you maybe you
throw out an ad lib and get a laugh and
hey shut the [__] up okay that wasn't
really funny but okay I got a laugh you
know so it it was that it was sort of
comforting because it wasn't my fault
well I used to go into bars I put a $50
bill on the bar and I would save the
BART can I do comedy no I go okay it's
50 bucks if I do bad and people leave
keep the 50 if I do good and they laugh
give me the 50 back okay that cost you
about
$500 but it also would a couple of times
they'd say yeah yeah come back on
Wednesday we got a like a what they used
to call him a hoot NY night it was folks
say yeah come back you get MC oh okay
and and and that sort of led into it so
I was a bit fortunate you know when you
when you come to Los Angeles I would
meet new Comedians and they would walk
into The Comedy Store of the Improv and
Robin Williams on stage and Jerry
Seinfeld and David lman and and they go
man and they would just be so
intimidated they couldn't even go on the
places I work
worked the audiences were terrible The
Acts were
terrible so I really didn't feel I was
that bad it wasn't until I came here
went whoa I gota get I got to get my act
together these guys are really good you
know so it was actually rather
comforting that's such an interesting
point I guess where I was going with it
it does take you know a lot of
determination to come into a place and
you know I'll give you $50 to be able to
perform what was it that drove you to do
that why did you have that tenacity to
to to keep going when you know you're
not crushing it you're not in front of
lots of people you're not making money
Etc I'm a huge believer in low
self-esteem I think it's the key to
success if you don't think you're the
smartest person in the room you listen
you know and I realize there's nothing
else I really enjoyed doing I'm I'm
dyslexic so I a Terri terrible student
and I I enjoy talking to people and
telling stories and to your F you know
you're the class clown at school all
that kind of stuff and you would get
laughs it seemed like I figured I would
do it until I just had to get a real job
cuz no matter how bad it
was it
was not as bad as not doing it you know
what I mean because you're on stage the
lights on you oh I worked awful place I
I worked one place with the guy said the
beach comber in AA Massachusetts he said
when you come just wear your old clo I
go I want to dress up just wear your own
clothes
why okay well because the guys the smoke
the cigarettes down and then they flick
them on you know so I'm on stage once
and I hear the audience laughing when
I'm not like and my my jacket's on fire
because the guy flicked a cigarette I
had a wool suit on and it started
smoking you know yeah wow yeah I might
tell you a funny story I was at a uh
Place F place in Boston like just a
tough place and I'm on stage and some
guy's being seated you know and they
they seat him right next next to a pole
because I can't see just shut up and
watch the show everything okay
everything okay Miss L don't worry
about and then I
hear and what was that and then people
laugh like they dragg this guy out and I
come up stage said they said oh the guy
was hassling about a seat why do you
scream uh
Billy Billy the bouncer had stabbed him
in in the leg with a knife and just cut
him up you know and the guy's bleeding
so they gave him 20 bucks put him a cab
send them off okay okay so fine so those
were the days yeah so then like a month
later I get a call from the club I hey
Jay I say remember Billy the bouncer the
guy that helped you what do you mean
help remember there was a Heckler and
and Billy stabbed him I go what that
didn't really help me well what's the
problem he goes and and this is my
favorite he say well he killed the guy
and now the cops are hassling
him and I actually said to the CL I said
well you think the cops will go after
real
criminal like Billy and the club goes
yeah exactly exactly and it it just it
just it just made me I mean that's what
you were dealing with and it was it just
very odd very funny just curious working
with strippers I loved it because I was
a kid I was 19 and most of these
strippers it's not like now most of
these strippers were women
that didn't type weren't in the
secretarial pool and there weren't a lot
of a lot of them were in their 40s and I
used to work with these two women Lily
Pagan and I need a man that was their
name and we would drive out to army
bases and they would set up like a giant
champagne glass you know have nails
their mouth put it together fill it with
water and take a bath and it well I told
Joe okay but they I was like a son to
them right and they have the big they
had their head shaved but they were wigs
you know but I mean big
strong women you know so I'm on stage
one and she's in the btub doing this
right and the guy's heckling I mean
really just yelling me she just gets out
of the tub goes boom and breaks the
guy's nose blood all over the place blow
she gets back in the tub she's watching
the BL the crowd is cheering and I'm
just I mean that I mean that's what it
was it was a great life was very you
know my friends are working at Wendy's
and McDonald's covered in peanut oil I'm
working with strippers
at 19 I mean I loved it it was a lot of
fun and I again you don't realize how
bad you are you don't realize if you're
a good comedian or bad you first of all
you have to learn how to talk in front
of a crowd and get a stage presence to
to have that and the jokes at the same
time is pretty rare so the fact that I
was able to get stage time I always tell
young comedians you know your church
your synagogue your Pub if there's a
like a karaoke n see if you can M see it
that way you don't have to be a
professional opion you just on state you
say something funny oh good say
something else oh that's funny okay as
soon as you don't get a laugh okay let's
bring on the next you know what I mean
just to get that stage time and that's
what was great so I I love that era I
mean just you know want you punch that
guy in the face he was a big one just
boom just deck this guy and his friends
are all laughing his nose is smashed
there's blood all over the place
hilarious yeah that's a hell of a
microaggression right there yeah exactly
but Jay you also had a few brushes with
the mob didn't you when you were doing
those gigs yeah I mean you know you know
the real trick is you don't fall for the
Trap you know I remember where I was a
place called catcher Rising Star which
is in New York and uh you got the real
New York crowd right and I come off
stage I'm in the bar and this guy it
looks like somebody from MCA G look me
he goes you're a funny kid he puts $100
in my breast pocket this was 40 50 years
ago with $100 of ,000 you and I said no
no give it to the church or something I
go no no no no no and I didn't take it
and he goes you know you're smart you
don't take money from people like me
you're a smart kid and you go never
bothered me again and you realize that's
kind of how these things work you know I
know some people in shs they want to
hang out with thugs they want to think
they're living the gangster life hey
will you pick up this thing at the
airport for me well just just go pick it
up you know and then of course they get
arrested or whatever might I mean you
fall into the Trap but I already
realized by not taking out
$100 nobody ever bother me again yeah so
was all right yeah it's it's interesting
that you say that because you look at
people like Sinatra and then later on
rappers they made that mistake yeah oh
is it some some get through it some
don't but yeah yeah it it doesn't seem
like a smart way to go no no absolutely
not so so how did you segue into TV was
it via the comedy store in La well TV
was always looking for comedians
especially in the 70s and 80s uh standup
comedy not so much now on TV but but
back then it was a staple of any talk
show and there were afternoon talk shows
or evening talk shows and have a
comedian who could do five to seven
minutes oh that was the best so they
would come see you and you would you
would audition you know um that's
another part of the business I liked a
lot because you always got more work
from other comedians than you ever got
from an agent or manager you know the
idea it's always this Cutthroat business
and then I I always see that portrayed
that way I mean Steve Martin brought
Johnny Carson into to see me Harvey
Corman brought Johnny in to see me a
couple of times um I brought uh Ellen I
brought Johnny in to see Ellen
degenerous once I got a little bit of
Fame I mean you can't do every job every
day every place so there's really enough
work for everybody you know every Pub in
the country has a karaoke night or a
comedy night or something so there's
plenty of gigs to do and comedians
always helped one another I lived in
Boston which was odd because most
comedians were in New York so my place
was where comedians would stay when they
came to Boston I just de I hate to go to
Boston call this guy Jay L you stay at
his place okay and that's how I got to
know Billy Crystal and Freddy Prince and
all kinds of comedians yeah because
Freddy Prince I mean that was a you I
mean
when you saw the documentary about The
Comedy Store I wasn't aware of him I was
only aware of his son because the same
generation but you forget what a what an
incredible comedian he was he was very
good he was a young kid he was he was 17
18 when he started yeah but it was a
classic couldn't handle the fame thing
you know I mean rather sad and he didn't
kill himself ultimately it was deemed an
accident but he had a you know Freddy
would like put a bullet in a gun and say
go I'm going to go kill myself bang
fired in the S then pretend to be dead
and then she'd scream and you know just
just weird just weird you know and one
time there was a bullet in the gun and
that's when he killed himself that's
when he died I mean that's what I think
happened and ultimately that's what the
insurance company I believe ruled out
and Jay you mentioned being able to
handle Fame there are clearly some
people who can and some people who can't
do you have any thoughts on why it is
that some people are able to take it in
the stride and others really strugg well
you know was a great thing about doing
The Tonight Show because I could be
around Show Business Without living it
you know you know I love Charlie Sheen
Charlie Sheen's a friend of mine I don't
want to be Charlie Sheen so being part
of Charlie Sheen you know one day I'm we
had Charlie Sheen booked on the show
right so the show is taping at five
o'clock and I go boy it's four o'clock
Charlie yet no and the phone on my desk
Jay got a phone call Charlie she what
Jay man
in the limo we got T-Bone are you all
right I'm okay okay yeah but oh man they
caught fire the whole thing you all
right yeah yeah all right look Charlie
don't worry about it well I'll get a
comment get somebody F say Charlie had
an accident you know call a comedian
let's get somebody
okay I got the news on I don't hear
anything about it you know it's like let
me call a driver you know this is now
it's like quarter toi hello Joe yeah
it's Jay yeah who are you so I'm sitting
outside Charlie Sheen's house he hasn't
come out
you didn't get t- bounded in the limo
what no no and I called Charlie I go
Charlie what are you
two with a monster under the you think
I'm going to check that you're in a limo
or got T-Bone and it caught fire and
that's I mean it was it was so stupid
you know not like oh I'm sick oh okay
but the idea the limo and you got T-Bone
it burst into flames police fire yeah
yeah just hilarious I mean so that's
what was fun about doing the show I
could live that life and enjoy it
without having it affect me you yeah
we'll be back with Jay in a minute but
first we want to tell you about our
sponsor Verso in our recent interview
with Tim Urban he said we should be
talking about longevity and Longevity
science researchers like the biologist
David Sinclair have recently made some
fascinating discoveries on how to
mitigate or even slow down aging
altogether and that is why I'm using
Verso Verso is a company that translates
these incredible scientific
breakthroughs into products that hold
the potential to increase your longevity
and one of their products I take every
day is called cell beinging cell
beinging helps combat aging by
increasing something called NAD Plus in
your body NAD is arguably the most
important molecule in your body high NAD
levels improve your metabolism repair
damaged DNA and increase energy
production in your brain immune system
and muscles but as you grow old your
body's NAD levels go down and you can't
take NAD as a supplement because it's
too big for your cells to absorb that's
why Verso cell being contains nmn
Resveratrol and TMG these three
molecules work together to increase NAD
plus levels if you want to read more
about this check out the scientific
research Linked In the description of
the video plus Verso publishes third
party testing on every batch of its
products to guarantee that you're
getting exactly what you're paying for
so if you want to join us you can get
15% off by going to
v.o that's
v.s o and use code trigger to save 15%
off your order now back to the
interview you know I was thinking about
this when we were coming here to
interview you've been married since 1980
you're not you know you don't drink or
take drugs is that right no no I'm sorry
about I you know I just have no interest
in it it doesn't interest me it's not
like I'm on some moral high horse no
it's just not I was always I'm a car guy
so I was always a designated driver so
losing my license would be the biggest
fear I life you know so consequently I
was a guy to drive all my drunk friends
around that's fine and then roll them
later and take their money yeah but no
but uh yeah this is your addiction
basically yeah this is it here yeah and
how did you get into cars what what what
was it well you grow up in New England
there were always broken snow mobiles
you know in America you could buy cars
for $25 or $50 cars that were really not
that old five or 10 years old because
there were just so many cars in America
that there was Cars would be abandoned
in the field it wouldn't take a lot to
get them running and and that's what we
did you know in those days I remember we
found a Renault uh for CV which is a
small Mall you know and we had three
acres in our we didn't live on a farm
but lived in a rural area so we would
drive around the about I mean now of
course they call Child Services and the
parents would go to prison and you get
put in the foster home but my mom would
just watch out we were like 11 my mom
would watch through the kitchen window
while she doing ditches and we would
just drive the Renault around you know
and we rolled it over a couple of times
stuff like that and so that's where it
sort of comes plus when you work with
your hands you tend to get more of
appreciation how easy is to talk for a
living you know the idea that the
heartest healthiest when the head and
the hands work together that kind of
thing you know so you're work then you
go out you stand on stage oh God this is
so much easier than taking a
transmission at me yeah I that's such a
profound point I think that's part of
the problem with our society Jay is that
very few of us work with our hands we're
all in our head right and that's why we'
we've come up with these crazy ideas or
we get offended by things that we
shouldn't get offended about yeah me
because we're not connected to the
reality anymore I I I suppose that's
true yeah yeah I I I yeah I think
there's certain amount of Truth to that
but again like I said it's low
self-esteem you don't think you're the
smartest I'm so fortunate to make the
kind of money to afford all this stuff
you know please you know I I don't think
oh I'm really good no because what are
you doing on a t that's my favorite
thing when I talk to Young comedians you
know I never ask
people I I always take the job and ask
what a days later yeah you know like
when I was doing The Tonight Show now at
the time I was I was a guest host and
there
were maybe a half a dozen or more
comedians that were also guest
hosts and I was the seventh guy out of
the six and those six are all
represented by the same manager and that
manager called me and said now listen
we'll go on to Johnny Carson and we're
going to ask 25,000 a show to host
and I said oh okay you I'm getting $512
a show to host which was scale yeah he
said' no we're getting it I said you
getting her yeah we got it last week so
and so you got it so and so whenever
they host I said you know I'm going to
stick with the
$512 all right make a mistake I C okay
well guess who gets named permanent
guest host I mean Johnny owns the show
okay now these guys is costing us
250,000 a month L cost us 2500 a month
they all doing about the same yeah why
don't we go with L okay and then the
money comes later you know I I always
meet comedians that just I'm not working
for that kind of money what are you
doing on a Tuesday that's worth $5,000
really really and that's all been my
attitude about it you know if you're any
good the money will come later plus
there's a joy in doing it I mean the
same show I do for a charity benefit for
free is just as joyous to do as one it's
paying you a lot of money in Vegas and
sometimes it's more fun you know so if
that makes any sense that makes perfect
you really love the job yeah I think
it's great fun I I really like I like
the challenge of it I like but you know
you have to like people I'm amazed at
the number of comedians I meet that just
don't like people I don't want to deal
with those jerks you know no I'm not
seeing anybody after the show no
pictures well somebody goes out of their
way to pay you know a lot of money to
come see you why would you not want
please thank I'm say hello it's why I
don't sell swag I was oh you should sell
t-shirts and photos afterwards you know
they got out of the way to buy a ticket
I'm not going toit oh it's another 10
bucks to shake my hand thank you you
know it just seems a little uh yeah did
you ever think you'd be here no no I
never thought I would be here no it's
it's the most ridiculous thing in the
world to me I mean I suppose on some
level I probably thought wouldn't that
be nice but not not in any real world I
mean yeah no no I it never did so that's
why I am internally grateful you know
because like I say you know when I when
I got The Tonight Show I hir the best
writers I could find and the best
lighting people and I listened to them
when they told me I
sucked okay I guess I sucked so what
what we do to change you know I had the
same crew for 22 years I know so many
Comics that go through writers and they
don't let the writer find your voice
take a chance you know I never hired
anybody for 13 weeks I would hire them
for a year because it would take nine
months sometimes for them to go oh I
think like I would say just write down
everything even it's not a punchline
even if it's just a setup a store that
sells this okay maybe some one of us can
come up and and that really worked out
pretty good for me so well based on what
you're saying you sound like a really
nice guy J hey [__]
you that will be the moment from this
everyone's going to someone telling me
to go [__] myself go for it but it's a
very powerful message because what
you're talking about is humility and you
see you know in in any field or any
particular career the moment people lose
touch and they stop being humble right
that's the moment oh yeah I I I you can
trace that I am so amazed at the at the
um just typical the thing and then the
drugs you know I always say behind every
successful man there's a woman behind
every unsuccessful man there are two
women you know and that's usually what
happens it just it just it just makes me
laugh you know whether it's Justin
Bieber or so okay then they go through
the obligatory drug stage and then you
it's hilarious it just makes me laugh
because because how did you how did you
steer a path through that though how did
you steer through because you're very
self-deprecating you're very affable
you're a nice guy but when everybody's
telling you he this is Jen or you're a
big shot how do you stop well first of
all you don't have those people when I
travel like I'm in Florida this weekend
I travel by myself because when you
travel by yourself funny things happen
funny things don't happen when you have
somebody Advanced team go ahead and
clear everything out of the way you know
I mean it it and and you have to find
the humor in that you know the idea is
that you have you know I have a place in
Rhode Island U and I was there the other
day and I always go to Joe's Pizza just
a little place those
wingsy okay so someone said hey you got
to try this Nicholas Pizza all right so
go Nicholas oh there's a line that must
mean it's good I go Jay hey it's Joe
What You Know Joe speak Hey Joe how you
doing he goes what are you doing here I
go so I just lie I go you know I had a
coupon iig I figured I'd tried use a
coupon and he says coupon he we all
agreed we wouldn't use coupon that son
of a [__] using coupon now I wait hang
on hang on now I'm in this lie I'm in
this stupid lie you rather than just say
oh I want to try another Pizza you know
I'm try to dig myself out of it fin I
said look no I actually I just want but
that's what I mean those things don't
happen when you have somebody get your
pizza for you yeah you know what I mean
I mean that's sort of that that's really
the fun part of it it's just you you
meet the oddest PE you know like I get
uh like when I go back to New England
which is a very quirky I don't know what
I don't know what the equivalent would
be in England but I get what they call
Boston compliments this isn't Boston
this is a real compliment again I'm
walking down New Street this guy goes
hey Jay my friend met you in California
he said you're not an
[__] and I said oh well thank you
very much and then he goes no really he
said you weren't I said well please tell
him thank you very much and I realized
that's as good as you're G to get yeah
you know that that to his world that was
a compliment it and it just made me
laugh I wasn't offended by it but it was
just funny nobody would say that to me
if I had a finless some bodyguards or
people walking with me if I been hadn't
been walking by myself that wouldn't
have happened and I thought well that
was a that was that just made me laugh
it just was so typical of New England
that quirky Yankee kind of thing you
know yeah I mean
Massachusetts back in the 80s they
wanted to pass a mandatory seat belt law
well it's against freedom and and they
were selling T-shirts that had a fake
seat Bel on it so when you're driving
and a cop saw you it looked like you
wearing a seat Bel to go to all this
trouble I mean that's the mentality that
you're dealing with to show that you're
for freedom freedom that had your head
go through the windshield it always made
me laugh so yeah that's that's that
that's why I don't I don't have people
travel with me because the funny things
don't happen any by the way in that
backhanded compliment in England that's
a compliment that's that's how we do it
you can't just praise somebody you can't
just say you're great that's I I love
the English thing of no Noble failures
are somehow better than successes oh
fail sorry mate that's terrible come on
oh you prick you big successful you yeah
very funny yeah yeah we we hate success
in the UK oh yeah yeah yeah you know
have you noticed that I do notice it
Stranger in a Strange Land is is my
favorite thing I love watching immigrant
Comics come to America uh who is a
comedian a Chinese uh gentleman he had a
whole bit I just watched him the other
night about America's napkins I need
napkins when they go to fast food F they
take all the napkins and I just why
didn't I why didn't I think of that
because I'm an American so it was second
nature but whatever like Russell Peters
a very funny the Americans reaction to
whatever it might be the Immigrant
experience it always makes me laugh yeah
that is a really important thing for a
comedian to have that outside eye and
also to to like people and that's what I
got when I used to watch you show is it
was so obvious that you liked talking
with people yeah you know and the whole
political correctness thing was never
really a problem for me because I
don't I mean my attitude I I find when
you have a crowd they think as a crowd
they will side with the Heckler unless
you do something really clever but for
the most part but whenever I would get
heckers I remember times I had just
enormous fat guy and I was making fun of
his tie and I could see he was waiting
for the fat guy joke I never did one and
then he got
very sat down again you know because he
real I didn't go for the throw I didn't
try to I didn't have to kill him yeah I
just had to gently PR him a little bit
and you know when when people sense
you're not being cruel and now the
audience sides with you you know working
in audience is like working with an
orchestra you have to
learn you know I remember when Hillary
Clinton was running for president the
last time not this time she was running
against Jesse Jackson and all the other
candidates and I had a joke about each
candidate and the Jesse Jackson joke was
not about him being black but as a
candidate the joke about Hillary Clinton
wasn't because she was a woman but
because she's a candidate but when I got
to the Hillary Clinton joke I'd hear
this this guttural kind of guy laugh and
I think oh did they think I'm making fun
of her because she's a wound running for
president and I see women would get sort
of standoffish misinterpreting so I just
took the joke out because I I didn't
like where it went you know you just
it's like hearing a bad note in an
orchestra just right get just get rid of
that note just take it out you know so
you want to have
to to me the best audience is one that's
totally
integrated a lot of male a lot of female
a lot of different minority people it
just keeps everybody honest I mean I'm
sure you know as a comic playing an all
male audience that's the worst Because
unless you're doing sports jokes they
don't want to hear it you know you know
the women keep the men in line you know
and they you get the women laughing oh
oh not now the men like you too because
my date like you you know so you have to
learn to sort
of work the room you know it's sometimes
you can uh you know win the battle but
lose the War and who are your favorite
guests to talk to on your shows well I I
always like politicians because you know
when you're talking to Batman it's not
really Batman it's a guy playing Batman
you know U one of my favorite yeah I
remember Hillary Clinton had the
nomination locked up the election was
like 25 30 weeks away all of a sudden
this guy Barack Obama shows up and give
gives a speech and people are very
impressed you know so I said let's call
him so I call him up and hey we'd love
to have you tonight oh thanks Jay he
drives himself to the show he's got a
jacket over his
shoulder he walks down the Jake my name
is Barack Hussein Obama and I'm running
for president United States I say Okay a
black guy from Chicago his middle name
is husin nobody ever heard of you don't
even need to campaign I think you're
just gonna win right and he thought that
was a funny thing and we got to be
friends you know so he gave me his cell
phone number next time he was on the
show he was President of the United
States and this time the whole parking
lot was tented for like two acres so
when when presidential limousine came in
from a satellite you couldn't see where
it went under the tent and it was the
first time the president of and this is
why you have the same stupid friends you
had when you were growing up I was
talking to some of my high school
buddies I said you know when President
Obama gave me a cell phone number let's
call
it I'm not gonna call it you don't have
it you don't have it shut up I you shut
up okay now you're like in fourth grade
I said no I said what I said was okay
okay it's 12:00 that's 3:00 Becky I said
you want make okay okay I doubt it I
here barck here Mr President yeah Jay L
Jay what can I do for you uh should I
lose this number lose the number Jay
click and he hangs up and and it was
just like the funniest thing the
funniest thing it just made me laugh but
again the same stupid friends you had in
high
school do you like talking to
politicians well I just like it because
it's real yeah you know with a movie he
always have to do and you were good you
when the movie's awful you were
incredible and one scene you Sean
connory was one of my favorites yeah I
like Shan because he he was not James
Bond I mean he was the tough son of a
[__] that guy I mean he had been a uh
did you know he was third runner up Mr
Universe 1953 yes yeah I mean I mean he
was and he would come into the Tonight
Show and g j what's the latest filthy
joke going about G you know and I tell
him the joke and he would laugh like a
pirate like that I mean like the most
hearty and and you always hear the term
that's a knee slapper he's the only guy
ever actually slap his knee and do that
and like and he was just he was the only
guy when he came to The Tonight Show
because we had these little tiny dress
room he was the only guy that would take
a
shower at the studio and he would sing
all the Scotland
and and the news to go hey keep it down
down there it's not me it's Sean connory
you know and Sean Conor be singing the
show and he's just very funny just very
funny he was a tough guy yeah he was a
tough guy in fact one time um do you
ever hear of a guy named Johnny
stompanato Johnny stampado was a
gangster who was going out with Lana
Turner Craig Ferguson told me his story
it's very funny and sha Carney had a
small part in the movie and she was sort
of flirting with Shawn because he's a
handsome guy
Johnny St pulls a gun on Sean
connory he takes a gun Smash Up the side
the head don't bring a gun to my RO
Place EMP all the bullets out and gives
them back the yeah I mean yeah just
great just great yeah yeah it's in some
ways have we lost a little bit of that
you have lost a little bit of that I
mean that's you know my mother's from
Scotland the most conservative woman you
could
imagine she's the only man you know
Jamie that's Sean conry that's a real
man Jimmy I go ma I don't want to hear
it that's a real man jimy ma I don't
want to hear it Ma you know she never
talked like that about anybody but all
Sean
K do you have a website or do you plan
to have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be cancel culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so we'll you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easy
dns.com triggered that's easy
dns.com /t triggered use our promo code
which is also triggered and get 50% off
the initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and
censorship the world you're describing
particularly from the early days is so
different to the world that we have now
yeah it is different but I mean that's
is a progress I don't know you know I
mean I don't know how you you know it's
funny because everybody's SLE someday
Big Brother you know it's going to be
terrible but no nobody Thinks Big
Brother is watching Big Brother you know
what I mean I mean I remember you
remember the Rodney Kings thing incident
okay to me that was the day newspapers
died because that was the first time
news went
unfiltered because when you saw the
Rodney King thing on the news they said
uh six black men in a Hyundai were
driving 115 miles an hour which is
impossible a Hyundai from that period
and they got pulled over by police
and because in those days you had a news
editor who would look at filmo boy this
is uh this is explosive stuff this is
going to incite riots let's just make
you know like for example in in in
Boston a woman was never raped she was
accosted so that could be anything from
a wolf whistle to somebody pinching your
ass you know it wasn't you they just
just wouldn't use the term so the Rodney
King guy he filmed it from his from his
porch and he sent it right to the
internet and that was the first time
maybe not the very first time but
certainly unfiltered news just went up
people well that's not what we just saw
on the 11 o'clock news they said these
guys are speeding and all this other
kind of stuff you know so so we live in
a world now it's better because what
used to be the law is now against the
law which is good but unfortunately you
just see all of it I mean the classic
story is shock attack or
are up 100% okay he had three last year
you have six this year rather than just
say that then shark attack 100% people
oh my god get the kids out of the pool
you know the people are
worried the kids out of the pool what I
mean I know exactly what you mean we get
fed the stuff and then we overreact and
response exactly exactly so I think see
I'm I'm an optimist I think say I think
what happens is the elite have come down
a step or two and everybody else has
come up a level or two which I think is
great I mean you now have protections
you know like when you watch The Comedy
Animal House which is done in 79 there's
a funny scene where they're in this in
the fraternity and there's the Muslim
kid and the Indian kid and everybody's
just making fun you know which wouldn't
happen today and I suppose it was funny
back then but not if you're Indian or
Muslim you know uh those kind of things
does it go a bit too far sometimes yeah
okay but that's what happens with a
pendulum sometimes it swings too far
left too far right but ultimately I
don't think is necessarily A Bad Thing
and know you on social media do you use
social media no I try not to you know I
I I someone said you send some of your
jokes out and I did it and everything
just got so misinterpreted it just you
know just people mad about things I was
telling him a story before I was in a
Chinese restaurant with my wife small
family restaurant Mama's running the
register and like 12 tables and the rest
of the family is the cooking the back
okay I'm talking to my wife and and the
woman the older lady is just bringing
the AUD I said man This Woman's really
working her ass off and since this this
is right in the UCLA the college female
college student said ah she's a
server and I I said well is she a woman
first I said you know I I try to watch
what I say I didn't say waitress I
didn't say chick I I I didn't say
stewardess and if I had said server I
would expect you to say she's a woman
because I'm defining her by her
job so isn't she a woman I didn't say
girl and she just and S Credit she said
well I guess you're right I go well okay
but I mean you jump on me first of all
I'm having a conversation with my wife
you know and I said I'm not mattering
but I just don't I don't see Point why
would you be a server before she's a
woman and then eventually yeah but okay
no problem but I mean that's the world
you live know people are offended for
somebody else I'm not offended but I
know you know and I think it's so
interesting you say you don't use social
media because people misinterpret things
I think maybe that's why a lot of people
feel like we live in a time where people
are really easily offended or whatever
because we all now live on social media
where everyone is bitching and moaning
and fighting about everything right
right yeah and realize one person has
the power of 10,000 people and if one
person says you're a Nazi well now you
have to defend yourself which seems
ridiculous when there's no you know the
number of people I meet that now believe
we did not walk on the
moon all right all right I mean it it
seems ridiculous
but and and what do you think about
comedians getting into trouble for jokes
and cancellations do you think that's
the pendulum going too far do you think
that's it you know well the idea of a
rape joke has the same career penalty as
an actual
rape that doesn't seem
fair you know I mean it's you do a joke
about rape oh you're cancelled you all
your TV appearances are gone or whatever
it might be if you actually commit the
crime
same penalty same penal so they just say
I mean I I don't know what the answer is
there I I mean you know Louis CK I think
is hilarious yep what he did seemed odd
to me I mean the idea the guy's brag see
that blonde over there with big boops
ride her back to my apartment went in
the other room and
jerk like a
legend I don't see I I it doesn't seem
like something I Brank about but okay
but I mean was his crime the same as
Harvey Weinstein yeah no but the penalty
is the same so I I I don't know I mean
I'm I'm sure I'll get in trouble just
for saying this yeah it it's we seem to
be this is my issue with it and see if
you agree and push back if you don't it
seems to me that we're living in a world
without Nuance where everything is
either black or it's white well yeah
exactly yeah that's exactly true that
that's exactly where it is like the lady
with server
woman why are we even having this
discussion
you oh you mentioned you're an optimist
yeah what are you excited about Jay what
am I what excited about what am I
excited about yeah
oh oh I mean your show is crushing it on
YouTube I'm very
jealous yeah we're doing fine I I mean I
I believe you're only as good as your
last joke really you know you know it's
so funny like I stopped doing political
jokes because
the people get so mad but they they want
to know the joke first before they laugh
is this prot Trump or anti-trump they
want to know where you're coming from so
I'm trying to write jokes that are
political but without politicians let me
let me try one of these two words
pleas all right this guy he's uh like a
young Barack Obama cosmatic speaker new
guy in his party pick democrat or
republican or Tor or whatever okay so he
gets invited to the big uh presidential
nomination convention in New York and he
flies to get walks in the M Square got
30,000 people sold out 8:00 the vice
president goes on Crowd Goes Crazy 9:00
the president Crowd Goes Crazy then the
senator then the mayor then the police
chief and the Postmaster General and and
finally gu looks at his watch and he's
got a speech his hand it's 1:30 in the
morning place is completely empty all
30,000 people are gone he looks behind
him sitting in the same row four seats
by guy sitting like this one
he says you know something that guy
stayed that guy stay I'm going to go I'm
going to give my speech is if those
30,000 people are still here because
that guy stayed so goes and we must move
forward and America must see the he
talks about half an hour he comes up St
guy still sitting there he goes down he
says sir can I ask you a question what
made you stay for my speech guy says oh
I speak
next I mean it's a political joke and
when I tell the audience that's what I'm
going to do then they everybody laughs
at it I don't lose half the crowd yeah
that's so interesting that that's the
direction you're moving in because and
see if you agree with this but when I
watch late night comedy shows now it
feels like they've moved in other
direction they're leaning into making a
point about the other team you know so
funny people seem been say to me boy I
bet you regret leaving the tonight's
show now Trump's president now you know
something when you like people it's so
much easier to make fun of them yeah
when you don't like them and I don't
like Trump uh and not political just
morally unfit through the
office it's hard to to to keep your rage
and okay now you're okay are you telling
me this because of political reasons or
because you think it's really funny I
mean there's always a joke should be
pure it should just be just pure jokes
you know that's the great thing I was
telling about Rodney Rodney Dangerfield
and I were great friends I know in 40
years I have no idea he Republican or
Democrat he just had
simple my favorite
he said uh I went to my doctor my doctor
said I want a urine sample I want a
seaman sample and and I want a uh and I
want a stool stool sample so I gave my
Underpants just just just just a stupid
joke I mean it's really funny I mean it
just just pure just just the joy is in
the joke I have no I meet so many
comments go I just want people to
understand how I feel about I don't
think anybody cares how I feel feel
about an issue I think we're in the
feelings age now though Jay like
everyone is putting all of themselves
out there for everyone to see kind not
everybody not as successful as Rodney
was because it was just Rodney worked
both sides just just did jokes I thank
you here was a joke thank you you know
Rodney Dangerfield had an incredible
story because this is a guy who when he
started out he he failed at his job he
fa becoming a comedian went away came
back well you know what it was because
his face did not look like his act yeah
I I remember I've known Seinfeld for
years and Jerry and I are really good
friends and when Jerry's like 21 years
old he looks 14 and he had a drug about
you know when you bring a hooker back to
your apartment I go first of all nobody
believes you have a got a hooker nobody
say she go back to your and we both
laughed at because he look so he didn't
look like what he was talking about yeah
you know so that's the thing and Rodney
he started out as a
comic and he he had a muse name of Joe
Anis you ever heard this name no okay
Joe Anis was one of those guys the
funniest guy of everybody stayed fright
to death so he would sit he would do
table comedy he'd sit with Lenny Bruce
and Rodney and all the guys and he would
just say stuff and guys oh can I can I
buy that can I have that joke can I and
and that's where he was like I knew
Rodney when Rodney didn't do no respect
he did like little bits he had a bit
about
uh he's this kind of Comedy is sort of
falling out where he says uh as your
captain speaking we're on flight so and
so at tww Airlines and flying over the
Grand Canyon right now look out the left
side of the plane you can see the
remains of flight 419 that crashed six
years ago Bob you were with me on that
one weren't you you
know that's what you just those sort of
character little pieces like that and
then I don't know if it came from Joe
aners but that whole thing about no
respect and starting to look like his
act it really came out of that I'll tell
you a funny Rodney story um my favorite
thing was when I watched Rodney on with
Johnny and Johnny would be the straight
man things are rough running oh okay J
but last week Johnny I got to tell you
you know and then because it was really
cold how cold was oh it was so cold you
know and just plain the straight man so
I I dreamed of the day when I could do
that with Rodney so when I got this mat
you ever had Rodney on things are rough
Rodney oh J I tell you terrible you know
so one day
uh about 2004 or five now Rodney's in
his 80s now and a little shaky and I
have on The Tonight Show and he's doing
his act you know and he's a little off
you know you know this gesture he do I
tell you but but the hand was like over
just a few little Mist I don't only
another comic would notice it if you
knew Rodney so while he was doing this
thing on the show I said to Deb produc
say call the paramedics I think Rodney's
having a stroke you know she goes really
go yeah just call him okay so Rodney
finish he sits now Jay how you doing I
tell you I'm okay today but last week
you know go and he was fine okay then
the show ends Rodney's his dress room
now the paramedics show up I said Rodney
the paramedics say can they take a look
at I'm fine I'm fine well he did have a
stroke and they took Rodney out in a in
a
Stretcher and a couple weeks later it
got worse and his wife Joan called me
said J Rodney's in the hospital again so
I drive over to the hospital and Rod's
lying there like this eyes are open and
she says the doctor says he can hear us
but he can't respond so I'm telling him
how much we love him how great he was
all his young Comics letting us work
Rodney the Rodney dille nightclub in New
York and how great he was to
everybody so he his why say go Rodney
Jan put your finger in Rodney's hand she
goes Rodney if you know it's Jay try and
squeeze his finger so I put my finger in
Rodney's hand you
know
and and
he and I I said to him Rodney that's not
my finger
and he and he did this he he just moved
for a second and his wife he and and to
get a laugh out of Rodney and that
situation it just it just really made me
feel good and Joan got it we weren't
being mean it was just he was a comic
you know but Rodney that's not my finger
and
he nothing changed except he just did a
twitch and he passed away oh probably a
couple days later but I mean it was
great to get that reaction from Rodney I
mean it was a comic to the end you know
it's a beautiful story Jay oh was
wonderful story he's a great guy he's a
great guy beautiful story uh we're going
to ask you a couple of questions from
our supporters uh in a second but before
we do well was end the main section of
the interview with the same question
which is what's the one thing we're not
talking about that we really should
be it's not my call it's your call the
idea well I feel you have to know I mean
as a society that's my favorite thing is
watching Jerry Springer I want everyone
on National Television to know about
this guy well nobody cares nobody care
uh what's the one thing we all need to
know that's not my
job you know I there you know there's
nothing harder than writing a joke I
love it when I see comedians get TV
shows where they're the inquisitive
reporter yeah you know why because
that's easier than writing a joke
everything's easier than writing a joke
it's the hardest thing in the world to
actually sit down and write jokes so
they come up up with any excuse I I
always hated it when I would like
whenever I go on TV I do stand up I
don't come out and sit on the couch
because people go as a kid I would go oh
I wanted to see him do I wanted to see
him do comedy you know no one no one is
interesting what you do is interesting
or what you have to say is interesting
or what you're sing but really there are
very very few people that are that
interesting so to
me you should bring something more to
the party you know that makes any sense
all right head on over to locals where
we ask Jay your
questions oh
wow Kelly Francis says oh my God you
must bring up the fact that Francis
doesn't know how to
drive
oh oh I wish i' had known that before we
started this
[Music]
interview